Nous avions chez les républicains
fixer des lignes claires
et tout ce que nous avons exigé
a été obtenu. Alors Gérald darmanah avale des couleuvres,
il fait des contorsions
pour vous expliquer que c'était encore 1 peu son texte
gouvernement a été battu par 1 motion de rejet
préalable, ce qui a été exigé des républicains
en commission Mist Paris.
Terme, nous avons tout obtenu,
peut-être même plus encore que ce que nous imaginions.
Ce qui compte au milieu de tout ça,
c'est l'intérêt du pays
et nous sommes celles et ceux
qui avons fait avancer les choses pour nos concitoyens.
Moi, je suis pas député pour
faire de l'appitrerie. Euh, politique.
Nous sommes députés pour que
des mesures qui nous semblent demain
pouvoir protéger les français
soient obtenus,
sur le droit du sol, sur la déchéance de nationalité,
sur la question de
la régularisation dans les secteurs en tension.
J'avais moi-même
des dimanches dit que j'avais des réserves
sur l'écriture du sénat qui me paraissait
pas assez verrouillé.
En commission permanente,
nous avons obtenu 2 mesures supplémentaires
qui verrouillent bien la régularisation
des travailleurs
en situation illégale,
notamment interdisant la régularisation
s'il y a 1 casier judiciaire
dès lors que les choses sont acquises,
c'est 1 bonne nouvelle pour notre pays